apesar da sua aparência doce inofensiva
a gelatina Pode sim encobrir uma série
de problemas de saúde longe de ser um
alimento saudável ela é em sua maioria
composta por açúcar adoçantes
artificiais e uma variedade de produtos
químicos completamente exida de frutas
apesar de indicá-las como sabor a
gelatina contém corantes e aromatizantes
que podem desencadear inflamações
compulsão alimentar e um apetite
exagerado por doces é importante ter um
cuidado especial com as crianças idosos
pois o fígado pode ter dificuldades para
eliminar os aditivos químicos
prejudiciais encontrados na gelatina
comercial as versões light diet
contrariamente Ao que se poderia esperar
podem ser ainda mais prejudiciais porque
os adoçantes artificiais presentes
nessas gelatinas podem confundir
metabolismo no corpo aumentando o risco
de resistência à insulina